people sometimes mistake the intima
Kanaka italia spider for an old Corvette
for a classic Ferrari and they're not
even that far off because this roadster
combines Italian design with American
heavy metal
the inter Mechanica italia was built
between 1968 and 1970 as a coupe a and
convertible it put Italian bodywork over
an all-american drivetrain the inter
meccanica Italia Spyder combines the
best of two worlds for a classic card it
has Italian styling designed by Franco
Scaglione plus the power of eight hearts
or eight cylinders in this case a v8
from Ford the Italia was filled in Turin
the car maker was into Mechanica
established in the 1950s by Frank Eisner
a Canadian with Hungarian roots the cars
he built almost always had American
engineering under the hood typically
from Ford or General Motors
[ __ ] Eisner the boss of inter mechanic
it was a real automotive
jack-of-all-trades he had an incredible
number of ideas and realized a great
many of them he was the first to build a
replica of Porsches legendary 356
speedster feistner died in 2001 after a
lifetime building very limited editions
of unique automobiles
the Italia is a prime example only about
500 units were built the courage design
combines elements of the Corvette and
Ferrari it was sketched by Franco
Scaglione who also designed a number of
Ferraris elegant contours and the
unmistakable proportions of a roadster
a long hood a low sloping windshield and
a compact muscular rear
and the sound coming out of the onsen
dual pipes is enough to make your hair
stand on to end
most Italia's were delivered with a
three-speed automatic our model is
equipped with a four-speed manual a
German car magazine in 1970 proved that
in fourth gear the Italia could be
driven at almost any speed between 22
kilometers an hour and 220 the testers
tried it out wow that's one sec I'm Huck
since I don't have summers hospital
the 5.7 liter Ford v8 has about 300
horsepower harnessed to a car that
weighs just 1,200 kilos
in the cockpit you quickly notice the
little imperfections that are common
with cars made in very small additions
a small price to pay for the fun of
driving this macho beast a well
preserved Italia Spyder costs about
50,000 euros we're rolling out of town
now at about 50 kilometres an hour and
in third gear when I punch the gas it
just pulls away with that typical v8
power hydrogen off power
another advantage of the American v8 is
that it's totally dependable and parts
are cheap and easy to find but is it
good enough to make the Italia Spyder a
real sports car or is it more of a
street cruiser like a Ford Mustang
if you have that state how does the
Italia spider drive not bad for a
limited edition car the chassis isn't
very stiff and that's something you do
notice the engine is something though
you just want to give it gas and hear
and feel the engine once you get used to
that it's a joy to drive